since it seems like about half the
country has snowed in right now
including
us here in tennessee my producer sent me
over
a trailer for a new movie you know
everyone's binging a lot of things right
now stuck at home
and he seems to think that i'm really
going to enjoy this
movie the trailer is for there is no
i in threesome sounds promising
let's take a watch
that's zoe she's an actress
[Music]
oh and this is me ollie i make films
we got engaged one year ago and have
been in an open relationship for three
months
so just first thing i notice even you
know they say we're in an open
relationship that's fine
but their pda their their public
affection is not just like you know sort
of kiss
appropriately first thing we see of them
is just like
slobbering all over just licking each
other's faces so already
there's something a little there's a
little off about i don't know i mean
when you get engaged or when you get
married just i'm not saying you don't
there's not
it's not fiery it's not what hot it's
not but it's you're not like licking
each other's it's
that's sort of like the lady doth
protest too much me thinks
i've got a chicken internet what that
means just don't do an image search
zoe and i are making this film together
[Music]
we're about to have our first threesome
you ready
they're in love but they also want to
betray each other
they're in love oh man they're so in
love
but they're also animals pursuing their
own desires and appetites
and utterly disregarding their
conscience you know and the objective
moral order
okay got it i am part german though so i
didn't
whoa was that so
i don't know maybe these people look a
little mods maybe i'm getting wrong but
you picture if a guy is going to engage
in a threesome
it would be more it would not be that
what they call the devils
three you would more imagine two ladies
and
and but it would appear from that brief
clip i don't know and you know people
look weird these days
it looked like that dude was kissing
another dude
hey i guess i mean if you're you know
open-minded
like that i guess i guess maybe it's my
own prejudice that i wouldn't have
expected that
so i did insist on some rules
the idea is to highlight an alternative
to monogamy
you can have your cake and eat it too
that's how it started
anyway so okay all right i guess
and now i'm once i saw the whips and
chains and that guy getting smacked
around by his girlfriend or whatever
fiance or whatever and that like the
weird kind of pagan idol on the wall
with the
like the with the giant antlers and
i'm not as surprised that he would like
kiss a dude or something like that
that seems positively bourgeois and tame
but
did you hear that lino said you can have
your cake and eat it too
right we want we have monogamy or we
have this whatever committed
relationship with these two but then we
also have non-monogamy and the thing is
you can't the thing about having your
cake and eating it too
is that it's not possible that's the
point of the expression
because if you eat the cake you can no
longer have the cake
but if you have the cake you can't eat
the cake not to bring up
old uncle aristotle in the law of
non-contradiction
but you can't have a thing and the
opposite of
the thing at the same time so you can't
i mean you can
pretend that you have this kind of
marriage or whatever but you don't
you have a sort of vague simulacrum
of a marriage but what you really are is
just a bunch of
degenerates sleeping with whomever you
like that's that's not a mirror you see
you have that that's the thing that you
have
but if you want to have a marriage you
have to you necessarily have to exclude
all those other things
i now have a girlfriend as well as a
fiance
you got a fiancee you don't need a
girlfriend
you like her i like it okay just don't
go
see her all the time jealousy is just
this thing
you know we talked about it
jealousy is just this thing that uh
you notice what she's i think implying
here's jealousy you know it's this
feeling
it's the you know but you should
disregard it what if you
shouldn't disregard what if the what the
the
feeling the intuition that that you are
viewing is jealousy or interpreting its
jealousy what if that is
your moral conscience and your
faculties of reason telling you that
something is wrong
what if actually the thing that you're
in inferring to be this
absolutely irrational kind of feeling
is actually quite rational and
you're actually perceiving something and
you should heed
the warnings of your concert i guess not
absolutely that'd be crazy
that'd be so crazy hi what do you do
we just have to have as much fun as they
do the competition
you told me you love me what do you say
you have secrets i've never done this
before
i want to stop if it wasn't for this
film
would you leave me
[Music]
what's about happening
there's no i in threesome that's funny
what's actually there's
exclusively an i in threesome americans
it's just only about
your uh your desires and you thinking
that you can have the good of uh
love true love willing the good of the
other person while at the same time
having the pleasure of purely selfish
sexual acts and you can't i'm not i'm
not saying you can't like i'm scolding
you like no no no
you know i'm i'm moralizing or i'm just
it is not possible because they're
they're contradictory acts
so you have because you can't have a
thing in the op opposite of that thing
at the same time
you have to choose but i got to tell you
i don't know this trailer actually looks
pretty good
because by the end they're saying oh
it's not working and don't me you would
leave me and
maybe this jealousy is real so i don't
actually seems like kind of a
at least somewhat promising trailer
maybe it'll be a very conservative movie
maybe i will have to watch this movie
over the weekend i don't know in my
extraordinarily
bourgeois sort of conventional
conservative family here maybe we'll
have to watch a movie about the reasons
i'll let you know
[Music]
you